It is literally like is the clearest
sign of just like some insane
insecurity. So she's got like, you know,
Twinkies or some [__] sat by her desk.
You got That's what we got to keep in
mind here. Stop making inflammatory
comments about Israel Palestine. I
shocking, I know. Shocking and crazy, I
know. Well, yeah, she's a she's a Hutch
moderator and Wick TV panelist. So,
[music] so yes. So, yeah, pretty much.
And you know, this guy's chill cuz even
Loner Box says this guy shouldn't be in
prison. So, basically last night, Pisco
had a uh like a a Christmas spirit
stream, [clears throat] you know, he was
he was on the on the eggnog or on the
red wine or whatever he was on on the
beers and uh you know, he had a little
talk about just Yeah, he was drunk on
stream. He was drinking on stream
and and he had a little talk about uh a
clip that was posted by one of our
clippers, Substance.
So, we're going to see him react to
that. And I think there's like a destiny
response to this now. And he got quite
heated apparently. I haven't seen a lot
of it yet. So,
>> is it fine if I say inane infuriating
things to troll? You can say what you
want for the most part. uh within the
rules of communities especially the
discord where we're making uh we made
some changes
but notice I'll just say from a
substantive perspective
the nature of the argument and what
people tend to focus on and I will say
the following I am not at all convinced
by and I know I wouldn't be right it's
not made for me
the kind of [__] that is being levied at
me with respect to some of the opinions
that I've held
a that any of these opinions relate to
like my attempts to cure a favor with
community.
I think that's like no basis to say that
whatsoever.
But also the character in nature of the
detractors. I don't really see them in
disagreements that often. And when they
do, they fold like little pretzels.
And so
my strat my strategy going forward is
not to back down from any of these
conversations. My interest is to focus
more on Trump stuff, political stuff,
legal stuff, no doubt. But um I am going
to rule notwithstanding, right? The rule
in the Discord is what the rule in
Discord is. I'm gonna get significantly
more chippy
and demanding in conversations because I
honestly don't think Oh, I think my dude
wait is Pisco take it. Guys, I'm going
to be so happy if Pisco has taken my
advice. If Pisco is
is doing what what I was wishing from
Pisco. I don't if you guys know, I was
there was like a Discord VC that a bunch
of DG retards that tried to stream and
record and all this [__] the other week,
but basically the whole the whole VC for
like an hour and a half was on one hand
it was Hobbit follower and Zip Zip
trying to convince Pisco to basically be
a worse debater to basically bend the
knee and just be like a total [__]
whenever he talks to anyone like H or
Destiny or Dan or whoever. And they were
basically like, "No, you should like re
beg them. You should like beg them to to
like please understand you and and get
on your knees and like completely mute
your argument argument in every way."
And I was saying, "No, you need to you
need to be mean. You need to tell
Archie's a [__] for not understanding
why it's important to draw a distinction
between possible and plausible. You need
to treat him like a a [__] [__] for
not understanding why you're asking that
shit."
If someone asks you, "Is this possible?"
you need to treat them like a [__] for
asking that question in the first place.
Like,
so if that if that is the direction he's
taking, I'm I'm very I'm very happy. I'm
very happy, me personally,
is not to back down from any of these
conversations. My interest is to focus
more on Trump stuff, political stuff,
legal stuff, no doubt. But, um, I am
going to rule notwithstanding, right?
the rule in the Discord is what the rule
in Discord is. I'm gonna get
significantly more chippy
and demanding in conversations because I
honestly don't think I think my patience
and it is patience even though it's been
um sort of
I think uh
slimed as like I don't know perceived
chippy like um
more on edge you know more ready more
ready to hit back more ready to be like
not not being like, "Hey, let me just
explain to you why you what's going on
here." Being more like, "Hey, [__]
idiot." You know, like being a bit more
aggro, being a bit more uh weaselless by
>> exhaustively going through things and
like walking people through step one or
two,
>> it's going to be a lot more just like
right to the point every single second.
And so, if you want to have those
conversations, I'm happy to do it. I'm
going to ask probably that you guys like
when you get in like listen this is for
big boys if you want to do this
conversation and um if you're not
interested in that you don't have to
have the conversation you can continue
like chatting what you want to chat and
within the rules of my discord and
within wherever communities you are
saying things but I don't think that
it's respected when people uh
are patient and nice. I really don't.
Right. I've been saying for a while now
I think it is true that like
people don't respect
>> God bless him through
>> and so I certainly am not going to back
down from opinions I actually hold I
think that the
response has been shambolic and pathetic
and it shows in the character of the
arguments which are all personal none of
the merits.
>> Is this about a substance clip? Is he
already talking kind of in reference to
substance clip here? Can someone link me
the right clip if he is? Um, and when
they show up, they they fold like
pretzels.
So, that's going to be my approach going
forward on those particular issues.
But it has nothing to do with those
issues. None of this has anything
>> Well, the talking about being less
patient is in reference to the Harch
conversation and the Destiny
conversation. Yeah. and the Lone Works
conversation. It's in reference to
basically all the conversations he's had
recently about the Ethan stuff,
but I'm saying like um has I'm pretty
sure there were substance clips that
prompted a lot of rant
>> positions.
All of this has to do with other stuff,
right? These positions I've had
>> like dude, these stories are comical.
This is comical. I'm sorry.
Saki Star has welcomed an alleged
Islamic Islamist extremist who labeled
British people dogs and monkeys and
called for Zionists to be killed into
the UK.
Is this the woman that was hunger
striking to get him free? This little
old lady, dude.
Islamist extremist.
And it's like his little old nan who
hunger strike to get him [__] free.
and
and him just like a normal guy
made some edgy tweets in 2010
on two discreet things. The San Global
Entry, we just read an opinion and Ethan
Klein lawsuit. These have been my
positions or at least most of the
positions that people take issue with.
There are aspects in which the Ethan one
has changed a little bit, but by and
large it's been my position for months
now. So none of this is like new
breaking news and it relates not at all
to it and my mission hasn't changed
because of it and I hope you guys if you
feel I saw there was there was one
comment it's absolutely unhinged. It's
really funny but like it gets
I me like it totally shows the nature of
the response here. So, I unsubed you
from you over the latest coverage you
had of Ethan's lawsuit. I previously
defended you against people that
criticize you for simply examining his
unhinged filing and criticizing him over
his attempt at the Savior Complex.
However, in the latest coverage you did,
you've thrown away most of your values
and morals in favor of dogmatically
defending the defendants of these
lawsuits in such ways that you make you
a complete and utter hypocrite on now
every previous convers.
No explanation, right? No explanation
whatsoever as to what the hypocrisy is.
no explanation as to a dogmatic defense
of these people. Dogmatic defense. In
what sense? We're only examining the
context of uh the justification in which
I'm absolutely ascribing culpability in
some senses, not just in sense that
people seem to want me to say. Uh but
there's absolutely no dogmatism involved
in these people. And but but the thing
is it's highly emotional. It's highly
emotional. Um, and the the person
continues, "Not only have you gotten in
the paint, hard against your own friend,
hutch over this." You used all the bad
faith debate tactics to intentionally
obscure each time with each unneeded
analogy. Parts of the actual case at
hand since you are smart enough to know
that on facts and merit, you've got no
chance in a debate on this subject. Not
the case. Not the case. Those analogies,
those things are meant to clarify. And
first of all, I don't think Hutch feels
any kind of way about it. We're totally
cordial behind the scenes. Totally like
Merry Christmas. Uh, one of my
>> Oh, yeah. So, I I think this is kind
like a relevant clip we need for this
this segment.
>> Why did you say soy pill is a maybe? Um,
I think I go above and beyond for trying
to protect reputations and I try to not
have people be [__] unhinged. Like, I
know people want to get hate for
whatever, but I think I do a pretty good
job. So, I feel like I should demand
somewhat close to another standard from
other people. Some guys at keeping your
community
>> relatively Yeah.
>> Well, especially compared to any other
[__] content creator. Holy [__] Um,
but if other people aren't going to but
like so like Soy Bill's community I
think is [__] unhinged about me. If I
So I'm I'm looking more towards how do
the communities receive me? And if it's
like super ultra [__] unhinged, then
I just don't want to.
>> Well, these people can moderate their
chats and they act like they can't.
>> These people are such [__] bro.
I cannot imagine deciding connections
according to how the community responds
to me. Bro, if if I decided my
connections based on how a community
responded to me, I would have gotten
nowhere.
>> Hey, Queen and I puked in a bucket and
it looked like Play-Doh.
>> That's awesome, Ky. Thank you for the
$5. Make sure you have some water before
you sleep. Yeah, it's just total cap.
>> People can moderate their chats. And
they act like they can't.
>> Was in our kick chat saying, "Oh, Steve
the [__] rapist pedophile, you're
really going to be on stream with it." I
like it's shrimp. Most respect that I've
lost for Pisco I think was in that last
more than almost any other thing where
he was personally mad or he wanted to go
in on me or whatever was when he was
like in the last com was like what do
you want me to do? You want me to ban
these people? And I'm like that's such a
beyond the point. That's such a stupid
[laughter] Well, not even it's not even
that. It's just like what like if these
types of people are in your chat saying
these things about I don't know. Like
when I see people say like really
unhinged [__] [__] about um like even
for Lykan I defended for a long time of
like don't just bring up the Aaron thing
or whatever like this is cringe or even
even for Lykan I occasionally said hey
please don't do that
it's a high level moderation there bro
high level moderation
>> for like Pisco like even after
everything I'm like well come on guys
you can't call him a fake lawyer like
come on but then like he has the most
unhinged people in like what am I
supposed to do and like
>> well they have like one one brief ban
wave where like oh guys if you're if
saying Lyan's totally controlled by his
girlfriend. He'd stop that for like two
days and then gave up.
>> I don't know. That's just that's weird
to me.
>> If your community is like even 20%
shit-talking, one person exclusively who
comes on your stream at that point, it's
kind of like you haven't moderated
nearly enough.
>> It's past the point of no return
feeling.
>> I think it says something about the
person. Yeah.
>> So funny, man.
It is literally is the clearest sign of
just like some insane insecurity.
>> My friends in in this party that we had
was like, "Oh my god, you
>> This is what it feels like to be Ethan
Klein. I feel like a drink idiot."
>> Thank you for the $5, Kabio. Thank you.
>> Hutch. A long time fan of Hutch. Um, no.
No explanation.
>> It was actually a great time show. I
need to uh I need to We need to pump
those likes up, guys. We need to pump
those likes up. What was it? Uh, dude,
what was it? King AK. [__] You remember
King AK47?
Get the LS up. Yo, get the LS up. What
the [__] What the [__] would he say?
And he had like the song. I don't
remember, man. Either way, guys, 290
people here right now. 40 likes on
stream. It's almost 250 people. Would
you mind please move the cursor to the
thumbs up and clicking it or pressing
thumbs up on a mobile device? That would
be huge appreciated. If you want to take
your support one step further, you can
donate directly through stream elements
link in the pin chat message. You can
also buy a membership the channel, gift
a membership to the channel, gift a
whole bunch of memberships around out
the chat. Buy a super chat which
highlight your message read on TTS. Buy
a super sticker which your YouTube image
or that we highlight in chat and I'll
describe it to you. You can go to
discord.gg/greamman twitter.com or
write.com.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Faith debate tactics used bad fa Can
anyone describe a bad faith debate
tactic I used? bad faith debate tactic
was me saying oh instead of possible
plausible like that's a bad faith debate
tactic is to clarify what we mean by
words
whatsoever
>> you have some of the worst takes of all
time in these discussion which takes of
which I do now hope and any and all rob
types clip and hit most rightly accusing
you of blatant habocship no explanation
about partisanship in what sense is this
partisanship in like for any party or
hide. This isn't about like political
view or expression. That's my whole
point that it's not about these things
and then it shouldn't be about these
things. No explanation of hypocrisy
whatsoever. It is now simply a fact that
Ethan Ethan had legal grounds to the
three defendants. Something I've never
said he didn't right had the moral high
ground on them too for all the
coordinated harassments their
communities engaged in. And this I think
is the kudigra. this guy. I don't give a
[__] if you leave. By the way, in the
subset, if if this is the state of your
mind where you're like,
you're just so angry, you're unable to
give any examples. You're like, you're
you're hypocrite, you're person, go,
bro. I don't need you. I don't want you.
Y'all can [__] leave. I don't give a
[__] But the the
essence of all this,
>> bro, you ain't going to break 10K if you
don't ban the funny chatters who mock
your guests. I know. It's
>> terrible stuff. Terrible stuff.
We're not getting loan in the box on
again thanks to Hodi. It's over. And
>> what's been unveiled is this utter
derangement on moderation standards that
is so openly one-sided, so obviously ad
hoc. I don't even need to say the words.
I don't even need to make the
comparisons. They make themselves. Um
and and so that's like everything. It's
a state of absolute derangement and
delusion. And I invite I invite
conversations with all these people.
>> Uh at some point we might need to get
like a moderator involved so we stay on
topic. I I challenge you. I challenge
all of you to take the time to actually
segment the conversations
and listen to what's being said. I think
people actually struggle with it. All
right, we have stream.
>> Hello. Hello.
>> I think this gu about the drama as well.
Belinda.
>> So, I think this is the really [__]
Hutch mod.
You know, that really [__] woman
that couldn't back up anything she was
saying when she spoke to Pisco the other
day and like calls into loner boxes and
just goes like, "Uh, yeah, I just think
these leftists are really crazy. You
know, this retard." So, that that's who
calls in here.
Belinda. Oh, [__] You're coming out of
the wrong ears. One sec. Blinda, how are
you? Can you hear me?
>> Hi. Peace. audio issues.
>> Yeah,
>> got to happen every time.
>> Hit me.
>> Um, well, the last time I was here, if I
recall, actually, you know what? If you
don't mind, and I don't want to spend
too much time on this because honestly,
I'm about as sick of it as you probably
are.
>> Yeah.
>> I ask you a question about the Ethan
Klein lawsuit [__]
Loner had an interesting idea that he
really wanted.
>> I guess that he just Yes. Loner. Loner
box.
>> Who's Oh, loner. I thought you said
Goonar had an idea.
>> Yeah. No, no, no. Boner Box.
>> Okay. Got a boner.
>> Gooner box. Yeah. Um uh he had um he had
an interesting idea.
>> Yeah. No, I heard the end of the call
where she's like
>> I just have a hypothetical for you.
Okay.
>> She's basically like, "Yeah, I just
think Jews should be allowed in
ethnostate." Yeah.
>> Add a little bit to it. So, you know how
um you know how Ethan called you a fake
lawyer?
>> I think he did that, didn't he? He did
not call me a fake lawyer specifically,
but I think he implied it.
>> Okay.
>> As qualified as his wife from PA was a
>> he said I was like laring,
>> but but I think it's implied.
>> Yeah, that was Yeah. Let's say that
Ethan decided to uh to do that. um to
like to continuously call you that like
to to like literally call you a fake
lawyer. And like
>> yeah, this is one of the these [__]
idiots and they are so [__] annoying
and I hate that they exist so much
online who is clearly literally just has
surface level takes they've heard from
streamers and just goes around arguing
it and then will act like they have some
deeper understanding of the issue. act
like they they're like, "Oh, you just
don't understand leftist anti-semitism."
What do you mean? The only understanding
you have of leftist anti-semitism is
watching Lonerox cry about Hassan daily.
That's all you That's all you know, you
[__] [__] And even then, you can't
cite any examples of him being
anti-Semitic.
It's baffling, man. to cover you and
react to you over and over again
continuously or like um comment on [__]
that you like let's say that he decided
to go after you as obsessively as they
say that he goes after Hassan. Okay. Um,
and then after that, um, you come out
with some video about something, maybe
something related to him actually, and
he announces, um, to his stream, and
he's like, "You know what? [__] Pisco. I
hate this guy. He's a fake lawyer, and
we're going to watch this video, and I
want you to come watch it on my stream
so that I can take all his views away.
[__] him." And because I don't want him
to make any ad revenue or money from
this. And then he does it. Do do you
really think that you wouldn't be within
your bounds to sue him for copyright
infringement after he said all that [__]
represent yourself?
>> When you say within your bounds when you
say within your bounds, what are you
referring to? Legality, morality, or
what?
>> I mean, like I I guess what I'm asking
is is
>> would you would you would you want to
sue him for copyright infringement and
also represent yourself while doing it
so you could you know as a [__] you to
him? Is that something that that you see
yourself doing?
>> If you're asking me whether practically
I would file a lawsuit on that basis,
almost certainly not. But I'm assuming
that's not what you're asking. I'm
assuming you're asking me like if I
wanted to file a lawsuit, would I be
justified in doing so? I'm telling you,
like I I would I would be probably more
likely to do a DMCA thing or something
like that if I was really pissed about
it or piss pissed about him doing [__]
like that. But just be aware of what
question you're asking me. Um because it
might just be obiated by some other
predominant concern which is I don't
want to [__] file a lawsuit for some
[__] I don't really care that much about
which is him being petty towards me. But
if you want to ask something different
which is if I did would it be justified
then ask that.
>> Okay.
Yeah. I mean it was Loner's question
technically so but I thought that it was
I thought it was a good question.
Hutch's mod's mod
was getting at was like
>> um
>> can't go two seconds a [__] face
lawsuit against somebody who had like
the past several months and actually I
guess you could further even add to it
and like every time you had a stream his
fans were showing up in your chat and
like spamming [__] or whatever.
>> Yeah.
>> You know to like further it Yeah.
>> You're asking is it would it be
justified on those on that view? Right.
And my answer is if I didn't care about
the underlying infringement or
preventing infringement, I think the
answer is no.
>> Okay.
>> And she didn't have to step away to get
food or anything, right?
>> So, she's got like, you know, Twinkies
or some [__] sat by her desk. You got
That's what we got to keep in mind here.
>> Do you care? I wonder if you would like
I don't know. I kind of feel like you
like maybe you might just a little bit
or like you might be annoyed at the
>> There might be some infringe there.
There might be some infringing that
infringement that I cared about. Uh, but
if I didn't care about the infringement,
if I don't actually feel like the
infringement um matters to me, in fact,
if I want the infringement, I don't
think I would be ethically justified if
that's what you're asking.
>> Is that what you're asking? Oh,
>> okay. Um, yeah, it is, I guess. Okay. I
mean, because I can just I
>> This is so trivial because if we change
this to loner box and Hassan, everyone
understands. Okay. So, if the if you
have seen Lonerbox do reviews of
Hassan's content in which he's like not
doing much in the given moment, right?
I'm sure you've seen it.
>> Um,
yeah. Although, yeah, I guess so. I
mean, Loner Box's React's always But
yes, I understand what you're saying.
You're you're going to say that
basically, um, technically like any
React content you could sue.
>> No, Lox just does lazy [__] all the
time, too. No, I'm not saying that you
can sue for copyright infringement.
We're just talking now about the
justification. All right. Um the
justification like if Hassan sued
Lonerbox for those instances,
>> you would say, right, it's not
justified.
>> Assuming he didn't care about the
infringement, assuming he didn't care
about the infringement, assuming that he
is saying, "Oh, I'm I'm only suing him
to
>> Was he he might be stealing my talking
points? It could just be that we're both
incredibly high IQ and reach the same
conclusions about this situation, you
know,
could just be that we're both incredibly
high IQ and uh came came to the same
judgment about this situation that, you
know, everyone's telling you you have to
think a certain way about
to support the socialist Marxist
revolution and all the proceeds I'm
going to do and you know he's lying or
like you know is to that end or
something and it's to protect the React
community, the socialist react
community. If he said something like
that and if you didn't think that he
actually cared about the copyright,
would you say, "Yeah, that's that's
totally ethically justified for him to
sue my my boy Loner."
>> Um, well, no, I wouldn't. But I would
also add to that. I would also say, um,
[__] that because that
>> Why is it not ethical? Because the son
hates Jews. Cuz the son hates you.
I mean, this is going beyond the bounds
of your hypothetical because I would say
that uh what Loner does counts as um um
as fair use. And to be honest with you,
like all of it
>> um yeah, most yeah, given the length of
delusional feel like
>> that's delusional.
>> I feel like
>> Oh, is that is that not true? Like is
that not I don't know how fair use
works. So,
>> I've I've seen Loner Box streams where
he's reviewing the content and like
sporadically commenting between like
playing a video game or it's okay. It's
a step up from like a chair react, but
on fair use grounds it's [__] cooked.
>> Okay. You're talking about stuff like
that. Okay. Usually when he reacts to a
song, he has a lot to say.
>> Not always though. What I'm saying is
not always in the case in which he's not
doing that when it's not fair use.
That's the case in which we we want to
examine. And the the truth is, and you
know, and I want you to grant it. If
this the roles were reversed, everyone
would be on the opposite side. You must
agree with that, right? The 95%. I won't
say everybody. 95.
>> Oh, you mean like all the people that
are [__]
>> Dude, stop stuffing your [__] face.
>> Correct. Correct. If I was [__] on
his
What does that tell you, it's Glinda,
right?
>> Are you
Well, no.
>> Holy [__] YOU'RE ON A CALL.
>> YES. SO,
>> NO, I get it. There's a
>> So it's not principled, right? It's not
principled. They are not principled. I'm
not principled. They're not because
they're they're inventing some [__]
They're inventing some [__] about
intentional malicious siphoning and all
that stuff. That's all made up.
>> Yeah. I mean,
>> yeah, exactly. Like I might go on I go
on to cake and I might like be halfway
through eating my dinner the one time I
eat in stream and I give like one
comment where I'm like kind of half
eating in like an 8 hour stream. This
[__] calls into peace go for one hour
of a day. You can't you can't set that
one hour aside.
>> Like listen, I'll be honest with you. I
just want to ask you that question
because I thought that it was
interesting that Laner put it to it.
I'll be like I don't actually care that
much about this about the Ethan Clyde
lawsuit and whatever his underlying
motivation shift was or whatever.
>> I I appreciate you saying that. No, no,
that's fine. You don't have to care
about everything. But this is why I ask
people and I get glad with this too. If
they care about it, because if you don't
care about it, that's that's cool. The
thing is people do care about it. They
very very much care about it. The fact
they're talking about it and they're so
[snorts] pissed they're calling me tank
supporters. They care about it. And the
reason I ask do you care is because
>> I mean people will say they don't care.
But the truth is Kinda your lack of care
is just be honest. IT'S BECAUSE YOU
DON'T like these people. If you liked
them you would care, right?
>> Um no. No. I mean I don't I don't care
that much about Ethan's motivation and
like I don't even know if like I support
the lawsuits or whatever. The thing that
I care about within this whole thing is
the extent to which that Ethan has been
harassed. I'm not saying you're doing
this what I'm about to say. But
unfortunately, a lot of the people, and
I think maybe this is why you got roped
into this, a lot of the people who are
supporting or who are against Ethan
filing the lawsuits or whatever, are
people who are against it on the grounds
that they also like deny the severity of
the harassment that Ethan has faced and
like the craziness behind it and the
reasons be behind that harassment or
they or they're okay with it because my
school's in CPS. Oh my god. Zionist
genocide supporter and that his wife is
like the raider of Ramla and all this
other insane [__] Like I I care a
little bit more about like the way in
which everybody basically him.
>> Did she go on a raid in Ramala? Yes or
no? Therefore, she is the raider of
Raala
>> because he did not tow the line 100%. Um
>> he didn't he didn't deserve that
criticism, right? He didn't deserve
those kinds of attacks. No, I Yeah, I
don't think that he deserved that
criticism. And I feel like it was a
waste of like it it just I guess it said
so much about the online left if this
was going to be their focus attacking a
liberal over this dumb [__] instead of
like trying to do something.
>> But doesn't everyone kind of [__]
know that lefties are cooked as [__] on
the Israel stuff and that they take
these like insane positions even u with
respect to people who are sensible
allies? Like they've always been against
liberal Zionists. always. This is not
something that the thing and and I they
say vicious things to liberal Zionists.
I just don't understand what the basis
of surprise is these kinds of unhinged
views regarding liberal Zionists or
two-state solutioners who believe in
Israel as a Jewish state. That is like
not new. That is as old as apple [__]
pie. And so the basis that oh my god
they all turn on the liberal zionist.
Yeah. The left is unhinged on this [__]
a lot of the time. And that shouldn't be
a basis of surprise. Now, is it unhinged
and still wrong for them to do the kind
of malicious attacks where they're
either lying about him or they're I I
don't even agree with snarking in the
first place where you have this kind of
like obsessive focus on a particular
person. I have no issue saying that. But
there's this thing where like two wrongs
don't always make a right, right? Just
because, and I think you would grant
this,
>> if they're lying about him, do you think
that we should lie back in response?
>> Oh, no. I I don't I don't think so. So
just just knowing that a party is being
wronged just just knowing that a party
is wrong doesn't resolve the answer.
That's what like there's two parts of
the equation. The first is were you
wrong and is your retaliatory action
justified. You have to consider both.
And anyone who soys out I don't really
care about the justification part. I
just care about the initial aggression
and not whether or not the reaction is,
>> oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no.
>> You guys,
the Mossad prefers Patreon anyways. Oh,
does it? Well, okay then.
>> Justified in light of the initial
aggression as to the means by which the
response is dictated and the target of
the response. That is just an excuse not
to think. That's just being a coward.
[__] that. I'm not I'm not saying you,
but like I'm just saying people who say,
"No, dog. Who auntie is that? [laughter]
>> I only care about that. I don't want to
consider other things. They're just
being coward [__] who don't." And it's
the opposite of what they accuse me of,
right? You get plenty of bonus points
for staying in line and for saying all
the right things according to whatever
your the ingroup preferences of your
specific community. I have the opposite
approach. It's like let's consider it
even if it pisses off your own audience.
So, it's actually ironically I think the
opposite. And as you sit here, is there
anything that I just said that you
disagree with?
>> Um I mean not not like super a lot like
I guess the main thing that
>> the main thing that's kind of
frustrating or like where I sort of
accident
>> it's kind of like a question. Yo, thank
you for the ride, Perry. Welcome to do.
How is he going to stop these people
from constantly cuz like the the level
of un unhingedness is like it's it's off
the charts, you know, the CPS call,
mailing skulls to his house, the doxing
and and I mean like really the H3 snarf
[__] he's been dealing with that for
years. It seems like at least part of
this lawsuit is him trying to like find
the H3 snarf mods maybe so that he can
sue them for something else. Although he
did complain in the past about the fact
that they were like stealing his
membersonly content and then like
rereaming it in other places.
>> I don't understand that either because
like Okay, so if there's a
justification, a purported justification
that wasn't actually given in the video,
right? So what you're saying here, what
people will do is they'll do this post
hawk rationalizations of the lawsuits
that aren't included in the announcement
of the of the video, right? So one that
they've done is the CPS call not
included in the video justifying the
traffic.
>> He didn't.
>> Yeah. Right. So another post talk
explanation is uh discovery rationale
not included in the video. It's unclear
to me a why we should credit an
explanation that isn't actually offered
by Ethan and just give like potential
justifications. But even if I granted
it, do you think it would be [__]
justified as a exercise of a fishing
expedition to get discovery material on
an unrelated case to do the case
initially? regardless. Yeah. So,
>> of course not.
>> Yes.
>> Of course not. That's not Yeah. That
like I said, I just kind of like um like
I'm not I I told you like I don't
necessarily have a um a super strong
opinion about like whether or not the
lawsuit was um a misuse of the legal
system or any of that stuff. I'm just
saying that like I don't know what the
hell else he's supposed to do to get
these people to leave him the [__]
alone.
>> Listen, I I I sympathize, but but here's
an idea.
stop making inflammatory comments about
Israel Palestine. I shocking, I know.
Shocking and crazy, I know.
But Ethan could simply choose to stop
discussing particularly inflammatory
manner Israel Palestine
>> either.
>> But but just because there's no quote
unquote solution doesn't mean that what
you do is therefore justified. Right.
Suppose that the only solution to get
them to shut the [__] up is to run them
over with your Tesla. It wouldn't make
it justified. So the lack of alternative
Yeah. Go for it.
>> Is there I'm just curious like um
because you know more about law stuff
than I do. Like is there actually a
legal recourse that he could take that's
not like some crazy [__] like DMCA
stuff? Like I the other only other one I
can think of is defamation, but that
doesn't really work or
>> to what? Right. Like to this to the CPS
call. Let's take each of the things.
>> No, not to that.
>> Okay.
>> Oh, no. I I think I think honestly at
this point I think that Bad and Banana
could absolutely be sued for defamation.
Definitely by Loer Bond.
>> Wait, then why hasn't he sued him for
defamation? I don't know. Um, apparently
there's a lawsuit, right?
>> It's it's probably because he's not he's
not in America. It's because I think
he's in Argentina, but like here like
yes, it's easier to sue these other
people because they're doiciled in
America. They're in places where it's
easy to do service of process, but there
is this thing called the Hague Service
Convention and Argentina is a party to
the Hague Service Convention and you can
absolutely serve people in Uruguay.
>> I don't know that Uruguay is in Uruguay
now. You know this? Yes, I do. I know
this. If he's in if if he's in Uruguay,
>> you know, I'm not sure there might be
some other process that Uruguay provides
>> for out of country people. Has he even
tried to look into that? I mean, if he
has and there is no feasible
alternative,
>> then that still doesn't help you, right?
Because you have to sue the people who
are responsible for the thing. And on
the defamation case,
>> yeah.
>> Yeah. There could be a case depending on
what the statement is that issue. And I
think that we should analyze it when the
argument is made when the like that's
the thing, right? Everyone brings up
these other things like, oh, he's
frustrated he can't get to these people.
Well, let's talk about maybe what he can
do to get to those people. what kind of
methods but the mere lack of alternative
doesn't by itself justify everything and
and that's like
>> no I know I know
>> okay so so so so talk talk me out
>> this whole basic thing wrong view on
this case do you have any view on this
case
>> well no I what
>> do you have any view on this case
>> this is this is the chippiness there we
go this is the chippiness
so you're saying you don't have a strong
view on this case you have any view on
this case this is the chippiness that's
what we want to see that's what we want
to see a bit of condescension
A bit of disrespect.
A bit of do you even think anything? You
know, that's what we want. That's what
we want to say.
>> Oh, on the I mean, not I I mean, like,
honestly, I could go either way on it,
but like mostly I'm just lying. [__]
>> It's kind of just been a thing that I've
been sort of popcorn giving. And I do
feel bad for you because of the fact
that people keep coming at you and the
way that you've been misrepresented,
especially by like people in DG. I think
that's kind of
>> Oh, yeah. I mean, here here was the
position. The position was that when I
said at the start to Hutch, do you care
about this [__] issue? That that was
bad faith. That when I clarified between
plausib possibility and plausibility,
that was bad faith. When I asked, you
know, don't you have the burden to show
that she neglected her chat and read it
and didn't chose not to moderate her?
That was taken as bad faith. all these
things that if it were done in a
different context against a different
target, people would celebrate like, "Oh
my god, I [__] own it." Like, and
then the ascribing of he's he's just
he's audience captured, hopelessly
audience captured by people who have no
[__] clue what a principal bone is,
have no idea how to maintain consistent
positioning. Um, and and this includes a
lot of the commentary class uh who have
examined that video. And I encourage you
to go through that video and try to see
the examples of bad faith. Um, it's it's
so laughable and preposterous and uh I
don't give a [__] I'm going to keep
speaking my mind. And if people
disagree, the great thing is they're
allowed to come into extreme
disagreements and debate it and actually
debate it and actually see where you
stand.
>> You're [laughter] not tired of talking
about this already.
>> In a sense, I am, but I'm very debatable
in that in in another sense. And here
here's the thing. If people continue to
to question and undermine, [__] yeah,
I'm going to talk about it. And they can
come into debates. The thing is people
come into the the disagreements channel,
what ends up happening is they say
things like, I don't really have strong
views on it or whatever. I don't really
have strong views on on what's what's
happening. And the people with strong
views don't come and don't talk about
it. And so I'm looking for all the
people with strong views on it. All
people say that I'm per say bad feed
that when I say they have a perfect
opportunity to come and have a
conversation.
>> Oh yeah. Um I mean like does um
I don't know did did Kafka have strong
views on it?
>> No. Right. He said it was he said it was
morally neutral that because of apathy
he doesn't support it and that because
he doesn't think it's in Ethan's benefit
he wouldn't advise it. That doesn't
sound like a strong view right in terms
of the moral implications. That that is
a correct summary of his views and how
was that
>> is also an attorney too so you know I'm
sure he probably has more information on
this than most than like I do like he
and he are probably on a similar level
I'm assuming when it comes to knowledge
about copyright and [__] like that. Um,
>> yeah, but but the thing is the copyright
case, the copyright issue isn't
disputed. It's they're strong cases.
>> What's disputed is my reason for talking
about this at all. As though that makes
any sense whatsoever given the the
parties involved and what people are
want to criticize, namely the ethics of
any given situation, including and
especially lawsuits. I'm actually going
to say a step stronger every time,
right? Not only do people sometimes
consider the ethical justification of
lawsuits, they often do. And not just
criminal cases, also civil cases, both
sets of cases, people will judge the
ethics behind them. And I'm tired of uh
actually [__] footing around. I'm
actually now going to be more aggressive
in taking these people on and
challenging, you know, their views about
it. Listen, you don't have strong views
about them. You're saying basically
>> Nicholas Dioro Nicholas Nicholas
[laughter]
Nicholas.
>> I don't The thing is is that if someone
makes a good argu like I I don't know. I
would probably have to think
>> mainly
>> like I said the main thing that I care
about and it's not even necessarily
related to the lawsuit. It it has more
to do with the harassment that Ethan
faces and like the reasons behind it and
you said all that stuff about how we
knew that the left was going to be
unhinged on this but I mean it's
probably I I don't know the extent or
how much you knew about Israel Palestine
before October 7th or whatever. like I
knew a little bit about it and like I've
since learned way more since October
7th, but I feel like um I don't think it
felt like everybody was taken by
surprise by the way that the left
reacted to October 7th and the amount of
like the number of people who were
cheering it on. Um and like it it was
the same thing with uh when Russia
invaded Ukraine. There was also a
surprise by how people on the left
reacted to that and how like they were
they either justified it or they were
indifferent to it or they didn't think
that America should support Ukraine or
like all these sorts of things. like
this sort of exposure to that was
something that I think at least people
why were you surprised by that surprised
by that?
>> Yeah, they hate American imperialism.
>> He was surprised when he saw that
leftist reaction to Russia and Ukraine.
>> I think America of influence is bad
people is because it was so ubi
ubiquitous across like I'm not surprised
at all. Well, first of all, I think that
there's a there's this like lack of
support for Ukraine among a certain
segment of either the tanky left or the
very hard left. And but that is totally
consistent with the left's um myopic and
here when I say left I mean the hard
lefts and I think
>> totally stupid view of um international
politics related simply to to to
imperialism and mainly through the the
the lens of imperial aggression and
colonialism which I think is a limiting
uh way to to see these conflicts and
oftentimes a reliance on America bad
foreign policy and this is not at all
new it's not at all new in the context
of Russia or Eastern European politics
where these people have been around for
decad and specifically on Israel
Palestine. I mean the criticism of
liberal Zionist is this is as old as a
conflict in many in many respects. Um
and so yeah I have this is not like yes
October 7th absolutely intensified
brought to the forefront in a way that
we haven't seen before given the
development of technology. Um and I do
put these kinds of delusioned views um
on the extent of culpability by liberal
Zionists on the nature of the conflict.
I view that as in keeping with um a
larger pattern of delusion on the issue
and um I think misplaced misplaced
aggression basically that anyone who
signs on to the project the li the
Zionist project but by which I don't
consider myself in any respect Zionist I
don't think that liberal Zionists um are
the problem the way that a lot of these
lefties do but that's just like not new
this is often been a way by which
liberals in America have been ostracized
and pushed out of otherwise lefty
communities.
>> Yeah. Okay. Hey, I mean I don't I you
just said something about Zionism that I
kind of want to move to in a second, but
first I'm going to ask you another
question cuz I'm curious.
>> Yay. Israel and left is bad. That's a
whole internet presence. I take it.
Well, yeah, she's a she's a Hutch
moderator and Wick TV panelist. So, so
yes. So, yeah, pretty much
>> because I think that it was the number
of people that kind of surprised
everyone like um unless maybe my
perception of it was wrong. Do you
consider Kyle Kolinsky to be like the
hard left?
>> Uh I think clo like a little closer for
sure. I think he's very skeptical. I've
heard him say things about Russia gate
in the context of the revelations
regarding Trump that I hugely disagree
with and that I would actually wanted to
talk to him about at some point. Um I
haven't heard him as much be in recent
streams be critical of Ukraine
specifically in the funding. Maybe I've
missed those things, but to the extent
that he says it, I'm totally against it.
I would say he represents
>> No, no, no. I'm not I'm not asking you
whether or not you're against it. I I
just was I I understand where you stand
on Ukraine. I just was curious as to
which people because I think like part
of this was that we were surprised it
wasn't just people that we considered to
be tankies. Kyle Kolinsky is like
anti-NATO and um he had a debate with
Vosch I think I don't remember if it was
before or after the war started. I think
it was after where he was he was
basically blaming NATO for the war and
yeah like it that's horrible. Yeah. So I
I don't agree with that. Right. But like
but that isn't by itself right that
position is one I disagree with. There
are a lot of political positions that I
disagree with and mere agreement.
>> Oh yeah. I I I I I know I I know that.
Yeah. I'm I'm aware like I know where
you stand on Ukraine.
>> Yeah. I want to expand NATO.
>> Not only do I want to protect NATO, I
want to expand NATO to include other
parts that are on like allies that are
in the Pacific. All right. So, I am a
NATO expansionist. I think that America
should be involved more um in world
affairs and should um you know,
gleefully accept these international
obligations so as to impose our vision,
our uh structure, which I think is
preferential. Now, I don't agree with
like I I want to be voluntary. I don't
want us to do like Iraq style ship um or
like Vietnam style ship to the North
Atlantic Pacific treaty.
>> Just keep just keep it NATO and just
don't worry about the Pacific part. But
all I'm trying to say is like your
viewpoints on those things. There has
been a robust debate on these issues for
years and years and years on NATO
itself, on Israel, Palestine. Some of
the views I think are I consider them to
be more serious, but the lefty
infighting thing is not new.
>> Harassment is absolutely horrible. I
Yeah, I know. But but I'm just saying
like I I deplore harassment. Harassment
is horrible and people who encourage or
want to actualize harassment should be
deterred to the extent of their
encouragement to the extent of their
harassment. No doubt about that in my
mind. And that is so clear to me. What I
don't appreciate though is notions of
collective guilt. You understand that?
like collective guilt. That's what I
don't I don't appreciate
>> because that's exactly the frame of mind
that would lead one to say, "Oh, well,
you're a liberal Zionist, therefore you
are culpable for all the things that
Netanyahu does or you're culpable for
the IDF
>> and when they did this or that or when
they when they raped the uh the
prisoners or what have you." Um, I don't
hold to that view. I think that America
needs to work handinhand with liberal
zionist reformers. I don't know. Uh,
frankly, I'm incredibly pessimistic
about the outlook for that and I think
that's being made harder by Israel and
its population, just to be clear. But um
like I am not I'm practical before I'm
an ideologue on that [__] Uh but all
I'm trying to say is like we should not
endorse that view of collective
responsibility which I think is typical
of that like mindset which we all
ultimately disagree with.
>> Yeah, of course. No, I I don't I don't
disagree with that. And by the way,
yeah, like it's okay. Like I I know that
you don't agree with all this other
kinds of stuff. You know, um Kolinsky
has also been I think pretty unhinged on
Israel Palestine. He thought that the
Houthies were based for kidnap for like
for like or that they were right for
setting up their blockade which is I
think incredibly silly. Um and yeah like
he's he's just he
>> I just don't see how that relates to
Ethan stuff. Yeah. I mean like you can
disagree and I
was trying to steer the conversation
elsewhere. I was just wondering about
whether like
>> it's so [__] annoying like this
[__] just comes onto chat
>> cuz what I actually came here to talk to
you about was not about Ethan.
>> Yeah. People don't people don't Yeah.
No, this is actually very helpful
because if you ask about those political
issues, you can see in which in which
ways I'm allegedly quote unquote giving
ground and which ways I'm not giving
ground where my principles are. So, what
I just said about me not thinking that
liberal Zionists are inherently culpable
will be taken like a bad way by lefty
communities um because they do view as
culpable. Now, I said at the start of
this, I am not a Zionist in which in
other words, what I'm saying is I'm not
ideologically committed to the existence
of a Jewish state on the basis of its um
Judais like the fact that it's the
Jewish character of a state. That's the
way in which I'm not a Zionist. I don't
believe that there there ought be I
don't have like a ideological
commitment.
>> Pisco using the same Zionist definition
I'm using and not the gay [__] liner
box one.
Wow. Wow. For Jewish people in that
sense. That's the way in which I'm not a
Zionist. But I'm so happy and willing to
if I were in charge of all these
different actors to have Israel live
side by side along an independent
Palestine all that stuff. And because
there are a lot of states that are
founded on things that don't make a lot
of sense or things I don't support. you
know, I don't support kingdoms. I don't
support um ethnost states of any kind
ideologically, but that doesn't mean
that I want to abolish every state that
exists. And that position where I'm
willing to abide the existence of a
state that has it as its character, some
sort of Jewish identity um should show
that I'm not a I'm not a committed
Zionist. But notwithstanding that, I'm
willing to abide the existence of an
ethnostate if it means peace. And that
is something that a lot of lefties would
consider anathema. We can keep going. I
don't agree with lefties on all their
politics. It's the bad faith shill liars
who say I do that I'm trying to appeal
to their sensibilities when it's not the
case.
>> No, I I I I understand that. I'm not
like Yeah, I wasn't necessarily um
believe me like I've tuned into your
content and it seems like for the most
part you don't even really talk about
this [__] It seems like you mostly talk
about Trump
>> domestic policies. Yeah, exactly.
>> And domestic stuff, right? Um even
though I'm now coming in here to talk to
you about I guess kind of a foreign
policy thing just because that I figured
that I would offer up my more I like my
perspective on certain things related to
it. Um because I don't know how much
time you spent reading about Israel
Palestine or like um what you've gleamed
with regards to it or whatever. Um but
uh like I guess Yeah. Okay. So you said
you don't consider yourself a Zionist,
but you also don't want Israel to be
destroyed. So that's you know um that's
fine.
>> When I say I'm a Zionist, I'm saying I
I'm committed u not to the existence of
a state whose character and identity is
um significantly based on its um
Jewishness. I'm not committed to a
Jewish state in uh either the the
version of Zionism where uh it exists in
the lands of the old kingdoms of um the
old Jewish kingdoms. In that sense, I'm
not committed to it. I'm also not
committed ideologically to um an ethnic
project, an ethnic state of any kind.
That said, I'm a pragmatist before I'm
an ideologue. And so ethnostates exist
and you know unjustifiable monarchies
exist and dictatorships exist and what I
want is a solution that makes people's
lives better in the long run. And so I
in that sense I'm like I said I'm a
pragmatist before. I was bought into
this consensus of the two-state
solution. The problem is that Israel is
destroying the possibility of a
two-state solution as though it weren't
already destroyed in many respects. But
by continued I think they just passed a
new resolution for um continued
development in the West Bank. Um and so
this is just more evidence that that
bipartisan consensus that international
consensus is a dim dim dim hope and that
is very scary.
>> No, I I agree it is. Um, I mean it also
doesn't help that at the moment there's
not really anyone on the Palestinian
side that has popular support for Israel
to negotiate with, which makes it
harder, but I mean it's a vicious cycle
because that Hamas and is um I mean it
also doesn't help that at the moment
there's not really anyone on the
Palestinian side that has popular
support for Israel to negotiate with
which makes it harder. But I mean it's a
>> wow. You know,
imagine if there was like a
political figure
that had been unfairly maligned and
imprisoned
by the Israeli state
that possessed huge popular support for
the prospect of leading a future
Palestinian state or or a new Gaza
project or whatever it be that Israel
could just release it and anytime.
Imagine imagine if there was someone
like that.
Imagine if there was someone like that
and Israel were just choosing to to not
do that despite massive requests from
like numerous governments across the
world,
you know. [laughter]
Oh, wait. Oh, wait. There is. Oh, wait.
That exact thing exists. Oh, wait. It's
It's my one. Oh, wait. that that's
literally what's happening.
>> Vicious cycle because that um Hamas and
Netanyahu basically feed off of each
other. Um and it kind of works that way
because Netanyahu is the security guy.
It's
>> almost like they've got all the power in
the situation crazy [__] that Netanyahu
can come out and say, "Hey, you know, we
have to go get them. We need to make
them safe. We can't negotiate. We need
to make you guys safe. We can't
negotiate with them." And then and then
like and then Hamas will see Israel
doing some crazy [__] And and it it'll
just keep going round and then they'll
say, "See, we can't possibly make peace
with these guys. They they just want to
kill us."
Marwan Baguti. He's awesome. And you
know this guy's chill cuz even Lonabox
says this guy shouldn't be in prison.
>> Etched on concrete walls, Marwan
Bargooduri's face is one of the first
things you see. Crossing the main
Israeli checkpoint between Jerusalem and
Ramla.
The image is coated with the smoke and
tear gas of countless demonstrations
against the Israeli occupation.
But his name hasn't faded. Despite more
than two decades in an Israeli jail,
Burguti remains the most popular
Palestinian leader there is. But
expectations that his name might appear
on the list of Palestinian prisoners
being exchanged for Israeli hostages
have been consistently disappointed. We
spoke with his son, Arab, a year and a
half ago.
>> I'm very confident and very positive
that my father will be released. But two
months ago, the farright Israeli
minister Bengavir posted this video of
himself taunting Bargoodi. The first
images of the jailed Palestinian in a
decade.
>> Even though Bargoti is associated with
the rival Fata faction heading the
Palestinian Authority, Hamas has
repeatedly put Bargoti's name on its
lists.
AB says it's testimony to his pixie
titan. I literally have no idea what
that currency is. R20. Thank you. Huge.
Appreciate with the shea presenting a
little a little bone with a bow in it.
Thank you.
>> Unifying appeal and why Israel would be
wise to release him.
>> If any Israeli leader really wants an
end for this and peace for the region on
the long term, they would see that my
father is someone that uh would bring
that. He's someone who still believes in
the tiny chance that's left for the
two-state solution.
So this Marwan Baguti guys, what he like
set up like a [__] university or some
[__] in prison basically as well and was
like teaching all the other [__]
Palestinian prisoners and all all this
[__] He's like the most like awesome,
you know, and it's like the the charges
against him are basically he might he
might have known or ordered some attack
during fighting. That's it.
and he basically refused to comply with
the uh pro prosecution, refused to
defend himself because he didn't
recognize the legitimacy of the trial.
So they just imprisoned him, kept him
there forever basically.
>> And then it just keeps going round and
round and round. Um which is kind of
like what they want. And so it Yeah, it
sucks. It's not good. But I mean I
didn't really I I don't necessarily want
to get into that too much. What I really
mean
>> but I just want to say like this isn't s
I know this is not surprising you. It
shouldn't be surprising any my audience
that I take the kind of like I don't
know the national security consensus on
Israel Palestine that America's
developed over the last
Thank you, Jimi, for sending a sticker
of Sabrina Carpenter in a hot tub
saying, "Hey, men and the men are pigs
and they devour Sabrina alive in the hot
tub and blood and hair extensions are
flying everywhere."
>> Thank you, Jim, for $6.90. Thank you,
Jim.
>> Last, which is the existence of two
solution, not the recent one, um that is
uh founded fundamentally on on the pre
um on the pre67 borders. Um so that
should not be surprising to anyone that
I would take that is like the consensus
view of liberal apologists of liberal
Zionist of um both parties in this
country for the longest time and so
there's not a basis or surprise in my
opinion or any kind of notion that
lefties are influencing my my politics
on this issue or any issue. Now on the
issue specifically of genocide I am
convinced on it over time. Um, but that
again that's just like a an assessment
of of intentionality that we can get
into. But um, but ultimately
>> did you actually want
>> Did you want to get into that because
that's um,
>> not particularly in the moment just
because I know it'll it'll excite the
masses.
>> I don't I don't I don't want to get into
that. What I actually wanted to ask you
about was more about um, it doesn't
necessarily have to be about Israel
specifically, but the last time that I
was here and I was talking to you about
Hassan versus Fentes. You seem skeptical
of the notion that Hassan would also be
bad for Jews, if not maybe in a
different way. um as like I guess
against or that Hassan is anti-semitic.
Do you think Hassan's anti-semitic or do
you think his actions produce
anti-semitic outcomes?
>> Yeah. So as to Hassan's anti-semitism, I
have seen the comments about pig dog.
That's what I've seen. The pig dog. I've
seen him say uh
what has he said? Uh let me
I've seen the the reaction to the Twitch
getting rid of Israel, right? Is that
something that happened? I don't know
that I have a
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. And also also Twitch uh Twitch
banned the use of the word Zionist um in
like a derogatory way because he was
like upset about that.
>> Okay. Yeah. So I I think there's more
like drama if we keep going.
>> I think
in the academy in these circles we call
it a microaggression and I would say
that that's discrimination.
>> Yeah. They talk about Hassan's
anti-semitism for a bit and Pisco
concedes that maybe Hassan has done
microaggressions against Jews before.
>> Yeah. Um, and like I mean there's other
like sus [__] that he has said too that
like I would have to like honestly like
I feel like Dan is the one who knows
like a lot about this, but the
>> Yeah, so have Dan come on and tell me
all the horrible [__] about Hassan and
in the meantime we can talk about the
Ethan Klein thing. You think he's going
to do that? [laughter]
>> Here we go.
>> I don't want to do that. He's want to
talk about can you tell me why you think
you won't talk about it?
>> Cuz he's lying.
>> Um, listen
willingly knowing very entertaining but
uh you're not a good debater and I think
that's probably why you don't want to
talk to peace.
>> The stuff he's saying is untrue
actually. What kind of chicken [__] is
this? This [__] goes on stream,
starts lying about me, saying I'm
griffing about lefty audiences. Doesn't
have the balls cuz he's a little [__]
to come on and actually have a
conversation about these issues. He says
I'm audience captured by Hassan Tank.
It's total ridiculous, total smear, and
he's too much of a [__] to actually
have a conversation. It tells you all
you need to know. These are all lies
that are being perpetuated and have no
bearing on what's actually in my mind.
>> Yeah, I I I I get it. Um I understand.
Um like I mean at least Destiny has the
balls to come on and talk to you. So
whereas um yeah, no I I just I don't
think that Dan is necessarily a great
debater. I mean maybe maybe he'll do it
if uh if like Loner would moderate or
something.
>> I heard that he was willing to do it if
if Destiny would moderate and I said
accept accepted. Accepted.
>> Okay. Yeah. Well, maybe I mean if I if I
manage to get on to Stephen's stream or
whatever, then maybe I'll bring that or
if the next time Dan is on loner stream,
maybe I'll say something about it. I
don't know.
>> Yeah. do it because um I I I find it
funny that um he actually has a closer
connection to the Jilk community than I
ever did. Isn't that right?
>> Um I mean kind of. Yeah. Oh, actually at
least.
>> Yeah. Yeah, he was. He used to go on
there. I because I remember that
community a long time ago like before
all the [__] remind me sometimes.
>> Did Did Destiny joke and say that um he
hopes that CPS gets called on Ethan
Klein?
>> Yes. Wait, did Destiny No,
>> I I recall seeing a tweet where he said
that.
>> Or maybe he did.
>> So
>> I don't remember. Oh, yeah. Yeah, he
went to that.
>> Is he Is he culpable? So under the
standard, you would agree under that
standard he's culpable for the
harassment of Ethan Klein.
>> Um, is Destiny culpable?
>> Yep.
>> Um,
>> any of these standards,
>> dude. She's so [__]
>> It's so insane.
>> Literally a brain damage moment. Crazy
brain damage moment. Like the most
explicit standard ever. Like it's so
[__] man.
>> Think of these are the standards. It's
like this um you want to talk about the
double standard in the context of
anti-semitism. Antipiscocoism is all
built on double [laughter] standards.
It's insane. Insane. And but I'm the
thing is when you have truth on your
side, when you have facts and logic on
your side, you can walk out with a pure
heart and say debate it anytime, any
place. Get a moderator.
>> Bring the information. If you want to go
step by step on all the videos, spend
eight hours on it. I'm here for it.
>> Yeah. Okay. Um, as far as the rest of
the anti-semitism goes, sorry, the other
part of it because like there there are
there's a bunch of different factors
that go into like like leftwing
anti-semitism doesn't look like
right-wing anti-semitism. I think that's
very often um like they're kind of taken
back by the notion of it because
right-wing anti-semitism is very easy to
identify and usually when people think
of anti-semitism, they think of Nick
Fuentes, they think of Jews control the
world, they think of, you know, like
Nazi Germany and that kind of
anti-semitism. Um, but I mean, yeah,
leftwing anti-semitism does involve
Israel.
>> I'm concerned. Yeah, I want to say I'm
very concerned about leftwing
anti-mitism. I think it's growing. I
think that there are multiple instances
of leftwing anti-semitic violence that
have occurred in the US. I think that
it's been a bipartisan consensus that
it's a problem. I agree it's a problem.
>> Okay, so he he spoke well we saw the
damn bit. Is there is there any more in
this stream? Does he ever go back to
this topic? Do we get more or is that
about it? Does anyone know? That's as
much I've seen [music] as much I've got
clbed.